Catholics how about Catholics how would
a cat like ever vote for Joe Biden when
there's actually an assault on Catholics
I mean I don't know how many Catholics
are who's a Catholic in this room how
would any it is New Hampshire so there
was that one guy who clapped buddy as a
Catholic because specifically Catholics
are targeted by the FBI and the doj and
then you're supposed to vote for Joe
Biden it doesn't make sense I will
direct a completely overhauled doj to
investigate every radical district
attorney and
an AG and a D.A okay attorney generals
all over the country it's Attorneys
General Sir they're attorneys they're
not generals they're crooked as hell a
lot of them are really bad all right so
anyway there's no evidence that Joe
Biden is going after Catholics it's
idiotic Joe Biden aside from the fact
that Joe Biden is Catholic now you could
be Catholic and go after Catholics aside
from that Joe Biden also isn't doing it